hello i'm kim dixon i'm the CEO of care
kitty productions around the head writer
and the CEO up with all the ideas for
the films and the stories I want to tell
from visual media and I guess I've been
doing this for the past four years now I
think it is my three years i'm not sure
but and i'm currently working on a web
drama which we did the first serious
fall and wasn't that God and but now
we've carried it on with a second series
which we're trying to get a lot better
the second series is three episodes long
and it's got a lot of plot twists and
changes and stuff in it it's good and we
have filmed patmos of the first episode
of it but mainly after being right in
this series but after the second series
there is something to follow up follow
and finish and tie everything off after
that which I am also writing but I'm
guess I'm currently right in what
follows on after that is I out finished
right in the cold blooded series 2 we
just need to shoot it now and with all
them we're getting ready for production
and I wrote it because I want you to
finish off the story from series 1 and I
love the cold blooded it's one of my
passionate shores and I brought that and
it's like I need to tie everything up
and I had so many stories I want to tell
with the main character and then the
second series I brought his wife into it
a bit she becomes a psychic the
cold-blooded is a detective show and it
is a crime drama and he's basically in
this world the real life version of
Sherlock but the university setting is
the same universe as a lot of my other
shoulder setting like it's got the spy
partners in which I made with one of my
friends
and and I haven't quite the script
because I just love like right in the
cold blooded and I'm always in the
mainframe to just come up with plots and
I'm always thinking news stories and
I've got the fall plot of what follows
or Africa series to which I'm keeping
very personal to myself series 2 of the
cold-blooded is a lot more personal than
the first series I guess you know where
with it being his wife as his sidekick
and there's or twists and turns along
that store alike and my girl with it is
to get it out there to the world to the
whole world knows about this show
because if the world knew about it and I
was making money off of it I would make
a million more areas if I had the money
which the only reason we aren't making
any more series after series 2 we're
doing something to tie all of its budget
wise we don't have the money at the
moment explore only a small company we
don't make money off of short films and
his films and his shirt and stuff but in
the future we will be making money on it
and we will use that to just create a
whole thing and maybe even if like a TV
company wanted to pick up the short hop
in the you know that's my ball a TV
company would buy it and make it or
something because there are so many
stars I would just love to say from the
cold blooded on the little screen um one
lesson that screenwriting has taught me
is that anything can be imagined and if
you can imagine something and you can
come up with a story around it you can
make it real and that's a big passion of
mine because there's a lot of things in
the world that people just wish you
could do and if it wasn't for film and
if it wasn't for screenwriting and
writers you wouldn't have that visual
for so you wouldn't be able to imagine
the things that we wish we could take
time travel for instance we cannot time
travel mess you get on a plane to fly to
tokyo on New Year's Eve internal to the
future and then by time you get back you
up the future anymore with past but yeah
that's
where we can time travel but I mean
physically time travel so stare for
instance girl from 2016 to the 1950s and
then go to 2035 it be completely
different and we can't time travel but
through visual film and media we can
time travel which I think that's why
screenwriting is important so that we
can get things our ideas and our
creative falls to the world and we can
sure what we are made of and we can make
things that just imagined look possible
and that is just what screenwriting has
taught me and and I right all the time I
right on the books I write in cafes I
write in my bedroom I write in the
living room I'll write anywhere I can I
say McDonald's and i right I sit in
starbucks and I right I single of coffee
and i right I just write anywhere I feel
like it on the bus on the way on and at
my partner's house I i will write
anywhere and my screenwriting doors are
to eventually come up with a fully
adapted manuscript of a script or not
manuscript but a fully adapted movie
script that I can then maybe sell or a
partner up with universal you know a big
movie company a big film company even
Hollywood could make it and that's my
angle to get my screen writing scripts
on the big screen and so the whole world
can see what I am made of and and my
screenwriting Korea I guess from when I
was young I always thought of writing
stories but I'm an actor as well which
is why I star in all my movies because I
guess it is cheaper for me to play the
main characters but I do always play the
main characters and still and I have
played non main characters but as an
actor and there's a professional actor I
you know I'm always coming up with
creative thoughts and my egg I'll be
getting on the boss and i'll be i'll be
on the box and I'll just think about
stories and listening
conversations and that's how I adapt
characters in my head and in a way Chris
in the cold blood which alas the main
character and he's based on Sherlock me
ah like Sherlock Holmes at me and like
people that I've heard in the streets
and but then his story and his story in
the series the story in the series to
like Chrissy's personal story arc in the
second series is quite personal to me as
an actor and out the Creator because
it's kind of something and like
especially in the fall seems like the
tides everything up from series 2 after
series 2 varies scenes in that that
would destroy me because I've seen
people like that and and I've lost
people in that way and it does hurt but
it's an emotional and impacting where
and I guess my screenwriting Korea
really I don't really have a career but
well I do because I'm writing all the
time but because I'm only young and I
don't really go I haven't even done my
gcse's year I'm doing them this year and
I'm then gonna go on to do my a-levels
and then I love English I enjoyed it
English his job writing stories and
stuff like that and I have a passion for
writing as well as directing and acting
mainly but I do have a real passion for
writing which I said why I am always
writing and coming up with ideas and the
amount of times I've written scripts for
people and they've loved it and I like
to get creative feedback and that is
what you need is a righty you need to
have creativity but so I guess my career
hasn't really started yet but as soon as
I go to university that's when my career
will begin unless I managed to get money
and I can open my business kk dear
productions and I can and just get it
out there to the world so yeah that is
basically my screenwriting Korea and
that
use me kyun Dixon as a screenwriter
thanks for watching bye